This is how I prepped for my video interview to get my job.
I work for a company called Yoga Club,...
...and it's a subscription box for women's activewear.
So, I took the time to sign up for the box, and become a customer myself.
Really get a feel for what that customer experience was like,...
...so that I could speak to it in the interview.
In today's world, the video interview is way more common.
You definitely want to test out your computer.
I recommend doing a quick trial run prior to the interview...
...to make sure that the sound is good.
You have to make eye contact and really showcase who you are and your personality.
It's a little challenging doing that, talking into a camera,...
...but I think that ultimately helps you stand out.